So it looks like we got some animal activity already.
Hold on. Don't come down any further.
We're here at
probably one of the most beautiful spots
that you can see in Big Bend
National Park, Santa Elena Canyon.
I am scouting for National Geographic
right now, looking for some native wildlife.
You get a lot of swifts coming through here.
There's warblers.
Right now it's the peregrine falcon migration.
It's a birders’ paradise.
Being a photographer
is all about putting yourself in position
to capture the best images.
Sometimes the being there is the hard part
because the access can be extremely challenging.
But I have everything I need.
I want to see if I can reach
some of these harder to get to areas.
We're on our way right now
to meet Ranger Tom.
Park Rangers not only understand
the layout of the place,
but they know exactly
the behavior of the animal that you're
trying to find, and exactly where to find it.
All right.
How you doing, Tom?
Good to see you again.
Awesome to see you, my friend.
This is a really great place, actually.
Probably one of the more productive areas
is along the river.
And then I would absolutely stop at
Mule Ears Overlook and the Chisos Mountains.
Appreciate you.
This is exactly why I love Big Bend,
because around every corner is a
completely different landscape.
We've got rivers, we've got mountains,
we've got desert.
That brings an eclectic character group
when it comes to wildlife.
But things like black bears,
pumas, bobcats,
they're really difficult
to see with your own eyeballs.
So I've set camera traps all up and down
Big Bend National Park.
Whenever an animal walks by,
the camera takes a photo.
It's always like Christmas morning
when you check a trap camera.
Let's go get some mud on these tires.
The first time I came to Big Bend,
we did it by horseback.
I've got a lot more horsepower
this time around.
Pop this long lens on, charge some batteries,
and then hopefully go and find some wildlife.
Hold on. Don't come down any further
because we got some animal tracks right here.
That's definitely coyote.
You can always tell the difference
between cat and dog paw marks
because dogs don't retract their claws
when they walk.
They’re going to come in here
to snag some water,
and that's why we got the trap
camera right there.
Set it back up.
Let me check my frame.
The only way to
do that is to become the cat.
Perfect.
Settling into a circumstance
where all you do is
have hope that it's going to turn out okay
and rely on your skill set, your passion,
and your motivation to get you through -
that is where the magic happens.
Oh, look at all these swifts right now.
They're all just over our heads.
Oh, what a cool bird.
If I was a swift,
this is where I would live.
The biggest question
I get is how difficult is my job?
And maybe for someone else
it might be, you know,
one of the most challenging things
you can think of.
But I couldn't think of anything else
I would rather do on the planet.
It's the easiest job in the world
because it's where my passion drives me to be
is out there in nature
chasing that next wildlife encounter.